[ __ ] it let's start this [ __ ] boys let's
do this yeah boys and girl I don't
discriminate thank you very much
this livestream has not officially
started yet but I imagine this is gonna
be up as well live for you guys who
didn't catch the stream so I might as
well pretend like there's actually
people what hey guys we're gonna play
outlast we're gonna play outlast - as a
live stream I thought I'd give it a give
it a try I would do apologize if there's
lunch like a bunch of [ __ ] that you
don't really care about there you're
gonna have to see it's not gonna be like
a normal let's play but him oh [ __ ] me
Edgar just farted oh dude you're banned
I'm sorry you're banned from the stream
go away go away Edgar that's right great
I should probably move my stuff a little
here so you don't so the the magic of
the live stream is it's not ruined live
stream is called and just chilling right
now we're gonna have to change that to
out live to stream and join yeah you're
Schmucks no I can't say that it will get
demonetised alright we're gonna fire up
this game as soon as we have some people
in here hey how's it how's everyone
doing all 62 people watching my god I
should really stop YouTube and start
streaming cos minecraft it's a video
game
speaking of Minecraft look at this I am
[Laughter]
Wow
that is incredible can you the science
the science that it's come far it's come
very far I'm finally in Minecraft
everyone what do you have to say about
hey we're a thousand thousand people in
here and someone just complimented the
quality Thank You Nicholas III do say
you know there's nothing a little good
old webcam can't do I I had these fancy
ass [ __ ] camcorders so it's old
soldiers problems it might be a little
bit delayed with the audio I don't know
if you're listening to like my let me
know because I can adjust that I can
adjust that [ __ ] just let me know
because I can't see it because I'm
streaming now it worked fine the hey
shade tippet how you doing buddy I was
thinking I'll do it a little bit of
gameplay and then I'll do a little bit
of reading out the The Tipping or
whatever the super chat markers don't
give a [ __ ] sup meme dad what's up
Marcus Felix The Walking Dead episode 4
oh [ __ ] you're right forgot about that
I've been away I just got back from
Italy I've been on holiday we might see
it in her family so I haven't been able
to catch up with a lot of things I'm I
just got back today but I Roger you game
time TV audio is a low low yeah I have
this problem with a mic that if it's too
loud it just speaks way too easily so I
rather just keep it low and then you can
turn up your [ __ ] volume sorry
thank you Mary black holy [ __ ] Mary
black my god hello from Mexico what up
Mexico what up my Mexican bros I'm doing
this because I know everyone in Mexico
does this or was it Hawaii there was a
way wasn't it I'm doing this because I
[ __ ] can't stop doing it doing my
mean why I said ironically does this and
then it's just become a habit it's a bad
habit terabyte games
I put put up I love you Thank You
terabrite a terabrite games I hope
they're not
bad games I will kill myself after this
dream don't worry about it I noticed
there is like a little lamb well thing
there it's kind of [ __ ] annoying me
that's better yeah it actually
disappeared how about that everyone I am
in Minecraft now I'm back in the studio
look real welcome all the new sponsors I
Rihanna Weber thank you hello hello
everyone hi from Switzerland a brofist
go 20,000 people up in this [ __ ]
Kayla Morton and markers Nielson you
guys are scenes combating that that ad
pocalypse thank you
what are we doing now Felix we are gonna
play outlast I'm just waiting for a
couple more people I'm a greedy like
that
hey from Scotland dude what up Michael
grapes top right I'm on enjoy yeah sorry
that's not Scottish
that's Scottish thanks Scottish just
sound like you have something stuck in
your throat
Jasmine mom I'm from Sweden Sweden
represent peopIe I love you so much and
you've inspired me to start gaming
channel can you check us out you maybe
give a shout out gaming adjustment let
me let me check you uh well your banner
is amazing it says [ __ ] I used to
have a hidden swear word in my banner
but YouTube deleted it sad times
dingo man what's up thanks for the mod
let's kill the spam Thank You dingo man
kill it dang a man is mod on the actual
videos I added a couple like 5 to see so
you know hold him accountable if
anything happens
Peter pie you used to be better hi from
Chile thank you so much that means you
know what let's put on some that means
so much thank you for your nice comment
honestly a
but knowing that you think I used to be
better it means so much it means the
world to me
I'm moving the wrong one it makes me
feel appreciated thank you this one it's
just for you buddy I'm kidding I'm
kidding I was a joke
there was a meme calm down huh [ __ ] I'm
too big now that's what he said
good stream hi Felix you you are making
a whiskey right I'm waiting for it you
know I would love to make a wish that'd
be dope it's [ __ ] hi Felix that's the
same one hey there how are you doing by
the way damn accruals
that's hilarious that you think that mr.
smiley face gaming that's you keep
thinking that Nico mockery you you're my
boy shoutout from Scott some Scotland
from Scotland are you you choppered a
moaning couple morning to you niko that
one's just for you William MacNair oh
it's all shit's and gigs until someone
giggles and Shh that's disgusting you're
disgusting William MacNair oh I feel
disgusted by your actions yeah it's the
best comment I got today
yeah thank you for that send nudes no
okay okay maybe later Jeff Faraj 20/20
from Jeff Faraj what kind of summer to
use your awesome thank you I'm using an
Chi MPD to one a along with Ableton Live
the magic hand Canadians Tito do you do
all stream on YouTube and twitch hit the
horn that one's for your tit oh and your
Terrace sorry no I don't I know I could
I just can't be bothered to much effort
I rather focus on one shot it feels a
bit greedy hey des thank you for the
shout out that's called day thank you
for the videos oh man there's a lot of
them popping in now make me a mood angry
you man that was not that funny you my
ninja from another mother that didn't
rhyme but okay huge hello from the land
of the pause Thank You Victor died
curvature bunny I'm sorry that was
probably offensive it's all I know in in
Polish whoa Kampai Kampai
hey I'm back oh [ __ ] I'll take some oh
gee enemy recommendation why not follow
my Twitter Quito key tokes
well fine but send me some in some
recommendations
what are you God boy or girl
I'm not discriminating I am just a
YouTube dude you're gonna watch boku no
pico series law thank you so much
playing persona 5 I'll listen to your
godly words I'm literally gonna go home
after this play persona 5 Devin hey Finn
family 20 hey son hi from Finland here's
question have you ever visited I never
been to Finland actually no I would love
to go to Finland
seems like a dope place if you guys have
any questions just put them in there and
I'll try and answer as many as I can
send nudes shout out shout out to the
red fox here we'll send your nudes
jackin young what a great name what a
great life to be living [ __ ] these are
coming in too fast now and I can't keep
up what is happening help
fifty thousand peep
watching this [ __ ] what are you guys
doing with your life what do you think
of Australia I think it's a [ __ ] I'm
joking I'm joking Australia's the
graters country that I would never go to
the first Jenny bean 20 that was sleepy
sound bite for you Jenny
poor sleepy on your hair Thank You Jenny
Damon my cigar you're a pretty neat dude
hey Damon you seem like an ear dude and
if I wasn't with mites yeah I would
definitely consider it
aleksander Bevin keep your spirit up
it's been around since you started will
always be a brother Thank You Alexander
that's really nice I always appreciate
those type of comments hey but it's fine
for a long time you've inspired me to
finally make my youtube channel
that's cool George all the best
honestly I really missed afar no Anthony
yeah well don't we all
but he's dead in the war the great wall
night Nikita George Rowe 14 point 93
that's very specific but thank you I
love you so much Fitz never give up
thank you thank you so much curtain and
Gorrell cheers to you random austere
gamey and keep up great work fan from
Australia got a lot of Aussies oh I know
it's late for you guys go to go to sleep
Australia all right no I want to wash
your stream with poop I reach out
comment what's so strange sounds like by
the way in case you were wondering shout
out from the middle of the ocean I'm
drowning send up someone send help to
ash Baker everyone ash needs help only
here for Edgar what the [ __ ] [ __ ] coming
in to pass all right well here's Edgar
there you go he's back
what it's me it's me guy Edgar the real
fan
they're real racing you here what can I
do for you ask me anything I'm here to
answer questions
I'm first me you're not Oh che
hey P BJ Valley in court hey boots
thanks for that day friends for Mike I
remember you my channel grew a bit from
your support I got another question how
did you deal if you did with people not
supporting you and believing in you
Patrik Vaillancourt thank you so much I
I don't know you just gotta keep keep
it's frustrating as hell when you make
videos and no one wants to watch that
been there but you just gotta appreciate
even if there's not many you have to
like I really enjoyed YouTube even when
I know I sound like I'm lying but I'm
not like I'd really enjoyed it when I
just had a couple people like even just
knowing like five or six people I was
like that's [ __ ] awesome so you just
got a don't don't compare yourself to
others too much have your own shame
Cheney last livestream you say you run
beer toe to sleep we during the
livestream but you didn't do it oh did I
really say that
I'm sorry sleepy is upstairs I would I
would I would I will do it it's from
Australia as well Australian never
sleeps well that's not good Jesper
Carlsen
cheers to you buddy that's one just for
you oh [ __ ] I almost miss a big one
56 smiley six lovely videos made
especially burnable trying this YouTube
thing but I am a full-time student
working at the same time any advice you
could juggle buff just stay consistent
on both and don't let one take over the
other and that's unless that's your goal
I don't know let's have fun with it
good [ __ ] man I'm glad you appreciate
the burner bo there might be another
bird about coming up Charles fish you
mark EMU and Jack Spade I see are my
Holy Trinity [ __ ] Jesus I'm not gonna
read that
what do you must look for in good
youtubers people that stand out do
something different I think it's always
cool that's what I'm drawn to can I
build you a new website kids I love your
content ever since Wall Street Journal
keep in a fire whilst you gentle put a
fire in my ass thank you Paul Merrill
that's Austin yes you can build me a new
website guy clearly need one heat Oh
cheers to you buddy
all the brofist but spate rollin 101
love your page you inspired me to start
my channel and make banners Walking Dead
and attack on tiny meters about you I
would really appreciate some help sign
up for your competition that's cool I'll
be sure to look after your channel speed
speed drawing let me find it properly
for [ __ ] sake where does it let's be
drawing everyone check out speed drawing
one at once are you drew me as walking
dead that's cool I think she's cool I'll
give it a like thank you very much
how am i sponsor XD I don't know what's
up it's why do you hate Romania I know I
love Romania it's my favorite country
it's my head top five 20 type hundred in
Europe
ya Yin Yang piers why you so fabulous
why are you so fabulous jigging you look
more fabulous judging from your avatar
hi from fan thank you being so nice
make me laugh every single day that's
cool thank you guys for your support
appreciate ya Jara Jara jinx hey
benabroad since you had hundred thousand
subs you guys helped me through
depression song and hard times thank you
for that keep being awesome bro and
don't let the price get you
same to you hara hara thank you so much
i hope you're doing alright and I'm glad
my videos helped I don't know if there's
a fitting button so I'll just click
whatever I actually fit it pretty well
Thank You Vera knock Mohammed Norwegian
bro Pierce you don't even need ads just
started YouTube read every day for the
damn said he's your fans are gonna
become homeless yeah we'll see how long
this lasts we're gonna become homeless
thank you so much dude
that's not the right button [ __ ] I
[Laughter]
ain't chill began Peter I remember the
first vid i ever saw you and I was happy
we'll it was happy wheels threw myself
over here five years ago you've been a
bra that long that's [ __ ] awesome
brofist to you reference to you buddy
it's mr. hat man again mr. hat man how
you doing buddy thank you
I shaved I haven't shade I promised I
promised I'd never shame just precaution
roses are red violets are blue jackets
bad pretty pie is cool that's the best
rhyme I ever [ __ ] heard in my life
sup from Australia
Australians are so nice love you love me
some Australian didn't type the other
one tonight
thank you he doe
appreciate ya david brining i loved you
since the first time i started screaming
Anisha you've been amazing ever since
thanks for the tears please say john
sucks but John doesn't suck but got him
uh shits coming in too fast
[ __ ] I peered love the pugs should visit
Taiwan I would love to visit our do I
need a talented software developer from
Romania nah you're Romanian I don't want
you I'm kidding
joke I don't I'm not looking for any
software developers but I keep in mind
thank you I love you content stay where
you are I'm not gonna go I'm not gonna
go anywhere I'm a monster
Thank You Jerome appreciate you alright
let's put some brake on all the super
chat cuz I I'm gonna play some [ __ ]
outlast for a little bit at least and
we'll see how that goes so hold the
super chat guys Marcus don't give a [ __ ]
first video watch where you outlets once
that's cool cuz we're gonna play outlast
2 live on the stream everyone and you
guys can finally okay I told you to stop
with the super chat god damnit brofist
thank you for a small a shout-out didn't
think you would see it but our dream is
to be youtubers to make a difference
even it's a little bit thank you so much
for from Texas brofist to Texas that's
so cool you guys are so nice
I love these streams
it boosts it boosts my egos so much
sorry I can't turn on the real name
right now here we go
is this too loud let me know let me know
if it's too loud
I'll try and fix it let me do the setup
I'm gonna have to do a new scene there
my sorry you probably don't see me right
now I didn't go away I promise
don't be scared
[Music]
so I'm just setting up just give me a
minute there we go that's the gameplay I
can't turn chat off I I don't know how
to do that
hey I'm back
[ __ ] I forgot I forgot I should have
done this before I forgot what I'm doing
[ __ ] I wish when is that how do I add a
webcam for [ __ ] sake oh my god why am
I so angry
holy [ __ ] Demon Souls four hundred US
dollars Jesus Christ
J says price
Oh Jamin sauce x11 7a pills hope you
stream well give us a good laugh with
your girly screams enjoy me thank you so
much
holy [ __ ] that's another one is a heart
for [ __ ] sake
here we go
hey it's me why am I doing this live
[ __ ] okay don't worry about it I got it
I got it let's just [ __ ] hey everybody
can you see this can you see my face
right now this looks [ __ ] creepy hell
let's play some outlast boys this looks
great
thanks for all the support guys okay
here we go
that better looks better me so I'll be
looking this way that should look all
right I'm taking you looking this way
that's a little [ __ ] annoying innit
what if I move them how's this now that
isn't making any [ __ ] sense now this
looks okay okay
how's the audio it's a - I noticed you
deaf have insurance what's your favorite
album doc hawk thank you my uber mood is
my favorite album Sun Sun but no I
should start sunbae there it's my
favorite and I don't know they're both
such [ __ ] great albums sunbathing
I'll go with sunbae there can I get a my
name a Jeff sample yeah
that one's for you buddy house house
that you want me on the right okay you
guys want me on the right I'll move to
the right thanks dingo glad demon souls
x11 seven I think
creepy face works well for this game
just get the campers thank you thank you
alright let's just [ __ ] play and I'll
try not get interrupted and we're not
gonna do super chat unless I get some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] obviously I'm not
gonna ignore it
okay here we go first first live we're
gonna continue off where we left off how
does it look I never it's obviously
gonna be some [ __ ] difficulties I
don't remember where we were it's been a
couple days for me [ __ ] don't even
remember how you play this [ __ ] so many
you guys [ __ ] hated me in the
comments I like boots I can't see the
battery laughs boots the game looks like
[ __ ] boots I [ __ ] hate you I'm gonna
watch text but I see I get it oh yeah
subtitles Thank You ding time TV see I
added subtitles it's always the first
thing I [ __ ] did but look are we
sorry
oops sorry guys sorry about that would
mop my bed hey that's a crank everybody
I got a crank let's crank it up
everybody let's crank it
let's head up that crank I'll head up
your mama's crank if you know what I
mean
also know that was a great joke by the
way also a lot of people pointed out the
doors have [ __ ] locks on them you
just have to look up there
oh I suppose to know whatever I've been
doing fine okay I haven't it's not like
he didn't do fine like I didn't do fine
all right so we need the crank to stop
oh [ __ ] they're coming in [ __ ] [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ] is there [ __ ] hide in the barrel
Oh [ __ ] mean water [ __ ] this is bad
brush
miss me a man our [ __ ] is out there oh
[ __ ] no you didn't see me ah [ __ ]
riding my tent
no stop what am i doubt the schatz not
[ __ ] helping lock the door lock the
door da-dum da-dum
okay the crank use the [ __ ] crank
we're
where do I put the Greg
[ __ ] the cranks clearly needs to be
there there but gosh why are you so mean
listen listen stop stop stop
everyone in ship run and hide oh my god
what do you think I'm trying to do
oh there's let me alone leave me alone
leave me alone okay well now I know
where to put the crank don't worry about
it we're fine he'll never find me here
he'll never find me here Fitz what do
you think of magic why are you asking me
that now out of all [ __ ] times go
upstairs to use the crank Thank You
little ninja chick finally someone
helping me alright upstairs how the [ __ ]
do I get upstairs where's it where's the
upstairs what are you smoking now
don't die thanks for the tip you guys
are great
extremely helpful all right here we go
let's take it easy where's the upstairs
I don't know where they are great great
I think you guys are [ __ ] trolling me
piers you have a PA box why are you
asking me this now
[ __ ] this I want to go back home I want
to go to Sweden game is a little quiet
all right well I'll [ __ ] turn it up
then boy oh that's not better all right
thank you appreciate their support how
do I need I got I got a [ __ ] crank
like where do I put it it's such an
[ __ ]
okay let's go on the other outside [ __ ]
what's with the [ __ ] country music
like at the showdown ba-bow
keep undercook Yulin okay that's not a
cogwheel listen whatever okay I
obviously have to stop the crank before
I go into the cogwheel ah [ __ ] you
didn't see me but here I am there's a
hole under the cogwheel at the Dead Guy
okay it's High Noon
it's so frustrating I don't want to be
live-streaming this [ __ ] [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
it
it doesn't work stop no this is stupid
[ __ ] this you're an [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever I don't
even care
whatever whatever okay there's a glitch
in the game clearly and go upstairs oh
my god super helpful thank you guys [ __ ]
am i oh wait this is where I get the
crank right and then the guy comes but I
can't go here because I'm too [ __ ]
slow
I feel like such a [ __ ] I like I'm
missing something completely obvious
let's check here oh okay oh wow look it
fits the crack everyone zero - zero -
everybody that's right
this is how you do it everyone this is
how it's done zero depth I want to thank
my mom I know she's watching love you
mom welcome Taylor shrilly thank you
everyone who subs subscribes all right
that should do the trick but yo what
does it happen what does that I never
mind you know I'm just gonna [ __ ] go
for it just let me pick that I didn't
[ __ ] see him ah
0-0 deafs go go go go
[ __ ] lock the door lock the door boy boy
I locked that door like a luck Your
Mama's ass boy
Pharaoh that
[Applause]
ah zip scrap everyone for more quality
content [ __ ] you [ __ ]
with sad news maybe [ __ ] ah [ __ ] he
made it in are you serious
[ __ ] this I'm out I'm out [ __ ]
guys how do I get over there yeah we go
down here no problem yeah
[ __ ] ah [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] yeah why they don't want to go
down here for all the white what's down
here
whenever you shout you're my clips like
a [ __ ]
amazing I'll try not yell too much thank
you Jew Justin love you love you Jew -
missed at you that sounded weird
batteries hell yeah
batteries when you're monix gone
anywhere if dumb batteries thanks Lexi
appreciate you yeah what is that this
place is not look good way no I'm multo
no gusta oh [ __ ] it's her [ __ ] it's her
all this I'm a bush don't worry about it
guys we got this not a prob bad battery
zero deaths everyone yeah Jesus don't
you ever quit
Jesus Jesus never quits but she never
quits
thanks thanks thanks at Chabot no no
come here
no no no no you don't want to be here
I'm a bush I'm a bush everyone calm down
everyone can you just shut the [ __ ] up
man I mean I'm with my buddy here his
name is yeah that's right that is all
right well I think we should go [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] back
run Felix oh no I made an oopsie oh no
please don't kill my boss thank you full
Mulqueen
[ __ ] she sounds like she's been smoking
for 289 years she sounds like she is a
smoke [ __ ] this is stressing me the [ __ ]
out man I don't know what to do
hello hey top of the morning to you
laddies it's Jess Jess
thank you you're amazing yes
man em where do I go where do I go it's
a walk in there that man where is she
she's gone
reload you must go inside where where
exactly ma'am where Bruce maybe that
thing where she our voice is turning me
on
what's that [ __ ] are you guys smoking
late night at 8:00 9:00 tonight that I
know what I am Laila blown it how scary
is out lest you I don't know how to it
from one to ten seven and a half peg go
to my name is okay [ __ ] where do I go
there's a gap in the wall somewhere
Russian go back to done' russian have a
gap in the wall what
she's cock-blocking me me just want to
get inside this long thing oh [ __ ] I can
go here oh [ __ ] dog
no here there's nothing here oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] pakka hater zero
depths everyone zero depth
[Music]
huh why does she want me so bad I'm not
even that sexy go go go go
here we go I'm out I'm [ __ ] out I'm
[ __ ] out peace out alright here we go
hey it's a it's a me hope you're doing
well
okay alright it's a cow don't look if
you're a vegetarian good one Felix
surreal surreal smoke made me Pierce
crane I guess this is a live stream we
can say whatever the [ __ ] why there's so
many dead cows the cows knew nothing
what's your name my name is yeah that's
cool buddy that's cool I appreciate you
all right
we're doing great find a hook find a
house okay alright no prob no prob
I'll find a hook guys where's the hook
tell me right now where's the [ __ ]
hook where's the goddamn hook everyone I
need that hook I'm hooked on a feeling
oh but chat up huh I'm with all the dead
cows that benefit just give her a Pepsi
bandages one the money's gone and you're
singing a shitty song bandage it's why
the cow so it's inside the
slaughterhouse
where you were thanks Russian being very
helpful Russian appreciate your Russian
we got to know what everyone excellent
that was really interesting bandage
s-sorry let me actually look at it I
actually no oh [ __ ] what happened when
the money's gone you can't go over the
slaughterhouse
so that's where I was I suppose it's
Laura house I'm guessing it's there
because that's where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right let's just take it really slow
and really easy and she won't find us
maybe there's the key inside that counts
anus oh [ __ ] I missed a really big
donation sorry enjoy
Jessica Scoy Jessica coy you have an
amazing sister you have an amazing life
well shout out whatever red ones get
appreciate you appreciate everyone you
guys are chuh caring now the
slaughterhouse which of course is say
here some well there's lot the
slaughterhouse must be here somewhere
this ain't no slaughterhouse
what
more dead [ __ ] I swear I looked
everywhere why am I so bad it's almost
like I edit out all the time so that I'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ] is this where I was
this is our pill I can't go back here
follow the goddamn blood okay
there's blood gymnast get better yet you
couldn't Felix would I get him to do
anything something humans threatening
going on da just say who contacted a I
only know this for me in about page
somebody can test that tag some fun so
where were we oh yes
this ain't no slaughterhouse [ __ ]
Casper what the [ __ ] that's not helping
Jesus Christ and I don't think I'd ever
appreciated how hard it is to scream cuz
you got a [ __ ] multitask so hard
so I got to go back so it is I gotta go
back
this is so [ __ ] hard to see as well
no way it's this way the dead end go
back the dead end okay I think I know
where that is
[ __ ] I'm getting such mixed comments I
gotta like distinguish wishes fake and
real it's really low on everything right
now look up [ __ ] slow I am how you
doing buddy
all right here we go
giant harder thank you why not just use
the text overlay in your game we should
really consider renaming your channel to
tongue into pie you guys are the most
unhelpful [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
great great one biscuit turn the crank
how do we [ __ ] do I get back to the
crank
that's like far away dude
the [ __ ] disappeared though it's kind
of weird
[Music]
this is really hard I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do
so she [ __ ] idiot
okay I'm just gonna not listen to you
guys and just trying to figure out
because not healthy I swear to God Felix
what [ __ ] dead end it's it ends
everywhere
all right
I'm supposed to look for a crack
that doesn't make anything for me
it's just a slaughterhouse can I at
least know that much turtle chips I
can't believe I recorded I'll get turtle
chips Thank You Kristen right I love you
lots don't know what to say brofist
Kristen right I love you likes to this
is where she was
I'm not cheating I just don't know where
the [ __ ] to go then with a whole fence
whole past the shed not through it when
I first saw her okay
I first saw her over here
oh yeah she chased me to the dead end
that's it
wow what a great stream everyone it's
not it it's that [ __ ] it god dammit
god [ __ ] dammit that's so annoying oh
my god thank you guys for this we did it
three hours later oh my [ __ ] god
Jesus Christ man holy [ __ ] I'm sweating
now oh yeah
oh this place is great man Wow
top of the morning to ya Wow this is
there's that there's the slaughterhouse
great ah yes [ __ ] great I can squeeze
through
Oh tight holes who woulda thunk it
everyone
number one gamer on YouTube she's number
one I should have prayed for
refrigerator that's hilarious
get it praying get it what am i filming
right now what the [ __ ] am i filming why
are you filming this
what the [ __ ] oh it's the P okay I get
it
damn that looks that's where the magic
happens you [ __ ] hurt my brain
conserve your night vision okay all
right you know that's a good tip I'll
try and do that
I've wasted more than I I probably
should have Hey look it's a chain let's
pull it everyone my god it
we're borrowing it Wow
oh look it's her again don't worry it's
fine I know what to do Oh speak that up
[ __ ] we're fine we're fine fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine everyone's fine
I'm gonna run for it I'm gonna [ __ ]
run for it
[ __ ] this [ __ ] boy where is she
[ __ ] this where is she I don't know
where she is and I don't like that
Go Go Go Felix go yes no no [ __ ] da
no that's the bear man she [ __ ] cheats
she's using hacks hide in the barrel
Felix Caleb Hawkins reckon it's better
than outlast I think it is Oh am i
hiding in blood how long can I stay here
Johnathan spawn thank you buddy oh I'm
in [ __ ] blood oh that's disgusting
alright why she so mean though
oh she sees me hide hide hide hide wait
another minute I'm a barrel bud no don't
hurt me I'm Swedish [ __ ] [ __ ] good night
ID gold my app good night have a good
one
good night sweet pea 2pac zero Depp's
everyone zero depth that was a glitch
clearly Robbie Bobby hey piers just want
to say thank you since the last
livestream the bros help my channel
still trying to find my niche seeing you
reach dead ends in the game is giving me
confidence to show my gaming love you
thank you I hid Robbie Bobby check out
Robbie Bobby I'm really [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that [ __ ] she's gonna
suck my fat ass literally really I just
had to [ __ ] run are you [ __ ] me
no open no open sorry got a little too
excited
yeah bar and get farted Nash Nash stop
spamming you will get banned all right
if you spam what's the [ __ ] point all
right
[ __ ] me there's the mind where the
heretics or kick the [ __ ] we kicked
that [ __ ] hard of course I'm gonna go
to the [ __ ] mind
all right great looks like honestly mate
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing
are you [ __ ] 12 Jesus Christ all
right looks like we're gonna need some
mods who wants to be a mind because
Jesus Christ anyone who puts up
something el mod just so we can counter
this [ __ ] spam Jesus Christ why are
there mods are there mods on you to
gaming yes there is and you're one now
will I play Walking Dead anytime soon
yes yes I will
why don't we do it why don't we do a
little break so I can reach out to
anyone that's donated so kindly hey it's
stuck isn't it I [ __ ] it I'll just make
myself bigger hi do you hear that weird
it's not the game
one second
ah that's nicer oh [ __ ]
hello Prime one how you doing oh this
game stresses me out like I hate having
to record a [ __ ] hour it's too much
man
I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] Thank You Osama
Ben ha sign for your Norwegian crowns
little nightmares coming out I have a
little nightmare I have a copy of it I'm
gonna play it whenever I get the chance
I'm really excited for it Jessica
Gutierrez I appreciate you very much bit
I appreciate you right back Oh a we got
a we got someone with the anime avatar
insta mod mod me you [ __ ]
mod me please dad Jeff I need help final
in two hours you should probably go
study instead your big baby
Samantha Mac new lobby Popo Thank You
Samantha our Roman and Fuu sigue I don't
know I don't think so
who knows who cares I'll be Ahmad it's
sexy
thanks for calling me sexy my name is
Geoff nerd nerd yeah my name is Jeff and
Dean Arizona Wow fifty
hey this shouldn't cover me using
adblock on you for like two years I want
I want to be mad but at the same time
that's alright appreciate yet this game
is spooky
Damon my sky sir yeah it is spooky say
the h3h3 intro what is it
top of the morning to you laddies my
name is Ethan and Gila please smoke
kitty I don't know early but I don't
think you ever saw it I'm sorry if I
miss them keep it up bro fights profits
to your Megan mode kitty I appreciate ya
I'm really trying to keep up with all of
them Alaina Wickstrom can't mod because
I can't stay but thanks for everything
you put into your videos means a lot
thanks Elena I appreciate ya would you
[ __ ] the zombie lady Pierce if I wasn't
dating Marzia and you know that this the
mood was set right I think I think I
might hit it and any girl that will
plunge a spear through my dick you know
there's something appealing to that OOP
knows gaming hey piers love what you're
doing man even if people think you're
not can my girlfriend get a shout-out
her name is Brianna Lange shout-out to
Brianna laying everybody top of the
market love you / - you're awesome
Jennifer Mills Thank You Oreo juice best
you two ever [ __ ] Wall Street Journal
please don't mind me okay Oreo juice you
exist pull hype it's green from Poland
sup polish bros or just say okay so I la
be pissed if I wasn't poor I doing it
why that's okay I appreciate any any
support you guys give Adam Young Thank
You Matthew me can thank you can i mod
your dad sure whatever Elijah I love you
piers can you do this to find out hey
egg boats
I mean Edgar kinda took over this hey
coach what are you doing I don't
understand
primer bars in 20 G's thank you
hey big screen for Germany can you say
welcome to you both welcome to jubail
fine net welcome to jubail funny so you
can use it
intro in a video okay great great I see
how it is 20 from Sarris Kois welcome
back Suresh guys I really love your
videos to pronounce Sariah I knew that
that's why I said it right Surya sir I
aha sir aha that bear please say hello
I'm [ __ ] my pants cheers from Mexico
hello I'm [ __ ] my pants she is from
Mexico at soy mexicana everything you
are really inspiration thank you welcome
Emily butter sir but Akash welcome
Lucius Draven anime recommendations ergo
proxies I'm rewatching it's [ __ ]
awesome
Gillies ex please sing for me piss Thank
You Julius ex how was that was I good
enough hi from Denmark please not spam
thank you notice me I love you forever
alright I'll do I'll stay for two more
minutes and then we'll get back in the
game
I want to get back with a zero Dex that
way I can't believe we have a zero zero
def run here everyone even even Tripucka
oh my god a block loophole I really
appreciate that you guys support if you
want to use a block fine
but it's really cool to see that you
support anyway add family freely
friendly Felix to your soundboard
intruder zero that's a great idea I
should definitely do that that's a great
[ __ ] idea the headset is messing with
the back of your hair that's true I need
to fix that volcanoes please play
welcome to the game 2.0 they made a new
one I'll check it out thank you for the
recrimination
welcome pepe welcome Mia Belle hi Felix
thank you for being awesome you were
just gotten me through hard times love
unit thank you me I appreciate you
that's really nice I'll Karis mod me
Felix okay fine just don't abuse this
pattern my dog thinks you're a [ __ ]
okay great dog can i be a mod yes you
can hey pills huge inspiration chatter
to the one they call Jacob they won the
call shake up everyone notice me Peter
by Grif 852 Simone Gianni thank you Mon
my family
Felix I hop green up to spam your wish
is my command
one more minute and we'll get back into
the game everyone Huff I love that
[ __ ] currency huff it's lit your
currency it's literally a weed reference
god bless you what country is hot I'll
move there I want I'm gonna all my
savings is gonna be made into hugs from
now on so I can puff them if you know
what I mean boy so the brows are saving
you in this game that's true jf6 2006
McCain great name how mid brought Bob
Rock hey puss shed some light on private
I'm working on clothes for Afghans kids
I'd go fund me I'll check it out
sounds like a good cause clothes for
Afghan kids look that up everyone chose
cat is not actually a toast cat then
what the [ __ ] are you you Danish
son-of-a-bitch alright 30 seconds I'll
just finish up you guys should stop how
do I become a sponsor I don't know I
don't think you did it right to be
honest try again next time but I
appreciate you Caleb snow Fox pits you
have other youtubers you have have you
and some other youtubers thought about
making an own platform I don't think
anything can compete with YouTube but it
would be good to have some options in
ways that now there's no way to monetize
your content that's why I'm doing this
live stream because outlast is not
getting monetized for me I am on YouTube
Gestapo list pretty much Jack mod me
please
alright that'll be the last one and
we'll go back to into the game and I
read out whatever is read or whatever I
got to make myself small again [ __ ] it's
cold it's [ __ ] cold in the office
today boss and go and dinosaurs and
Edgar's okay game
here we go we are back everyone top of
the morning to you laddies choppa Tituba
dt2 Tara we're going to do mines as far
as I'm concerned don't remember where I
came from zero depth yes right we're on
a zero deaths run everyone we haven't
had a single time in this entire
playthrough
I can't believe it it hasn't been done
before it's a world's first looks like I
can't get in here without a key great so
where do I go Circle ooh here I don't
think people watching the stream wants
me to spend time reading that so
um [ __ ] where do I go that looks like a
dead end
yeah that looks great good job go there
Felix Ignace thank you for turning on
the subtitles in the game thank you for
pointing it out I feel like such an
idiot
this is my vegetarian body I don't think
I have it anymore Hillary Clinton that
one's for you Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton I hope you're happy with that
one is safe a flash laws can't believe
you playing this while I'm at work you
can't watch it will be available offline
but thank you have flash lols appreciate
you this is where we came from where the
[ __ ] do I go then Marsh Mahalo
can I beam on well Jesus cries of course
you can okay there we go
this is distracting us [ __ ]
there's only one way to go for [ __ ]
sake all right there we go then I just
[ __ ] get hurt on a [ __ ] cactus
what the hell here we go
I got please don't pull out my
headphones that will [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
can have you ruining my headphones by
any tips kind of lost why am I so stuck
in this game all the sudden I swear
before the game kind of played it it's
up check some comments cuz I don't
[ __ ] know where to go
and go back to the door and jump
oh they're so [ __ ] sneaky
Thank You Russia Oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this
is before a foundry oh this is before
should recorded the team what that [ __ ]
is happening if that's supposed to be
transparent hang that Berlin to find
okay happy birthday Valerio oh god it's
a bad any so she hanged herself in the
school artists let's record this why did
you name your dog Edgar it's it's base
of an Edgar Allan Poe Thank You Orly
I won't be doing any more mods guys I'm
sorry can't thank you enough to those
came to the stream that's cool why do
you guys are supporting whoever is
supporting it's a cool community oh my
god for [ __ ] sake man it's so [ __ ]
dark and there's no [ __ ] batteries
this is not a life I want to be living
King Bach oh by the way Arizona is
actually the scary great now I wouldn't
know we should stay oh my god
now I know we should say I will never
[ __ ] visit
[ __ ] there it is what do I do
I'll live I think I solved it guys after
this dream I'm going to a hard part
my Jeff okay that doesn't help me
so I'm supposed to how the [ __ ] do I get
out of here find a way to get out of
here let's watch it okay that makes
sense thank you I've been pari it was a
[ __ ] those old slides that you have
in school I don't know what did they
call in English I thought it was a
glitch the [ __ ] is happening there all
right we just got to find one of those
must be here somewhere
you be slider whatever it's called
I should make a discord you guys alright
that would be cool
where is say I know what I need to find
I just don't know where it is
this is where we found it
okay [ __ ] this game is so [ __ ] dark
so quiet - it's [ __ ] creeps me out
man
zero deaths everyone am i just walking
in [ __ ] circles now okay could it be
here usually the teacher has it right no
it's not here jammed let's try and go
around where do I put it I need to put
it somewhere there it is it's jam okay I
need to get in there
but I [ __ ] can [ __ ] here we go
God um ah
let's move it the hair hold it to
interact God them that the letters learn
third third third third like not lined
up there's something how did you make it
yourself just move on dude what is he
doing
yeah if people if people spam like self
advertising yeah okay I'm fine with
timing yeah
watching you know that's to played
through holy [ __ ] damn the [ __ ] life
watching either really even though I
haven't played it myself
you're you're spoiling it for me also
you have time you peep my photography it
was my first passion before YouTube i
link to my Twitter Thank You elevado
I'll check it out after the stream I
have a tab open okay [ __ ]
push it forward that makes sense that
should have been obvious
unforgivable
yeah boy yo Felix did you see the
awkward handshakes nice I did no but I
can't wait to watch it now
hell yes Kasey's like the least it's
like not an awkward dude
so whenever like actually cool people
[ __ ] up with that things it brings me
joy unforgivable great find the
transparent in the other room I already
did
where did they dude unforgettable I have
some [ __ ] [ __ ] boy
screamer's boy dude
Hillary Clinton [ __ ] wrong button what
is just please it's so smooth the game
the game just got a lot scarier sorry
alright never go back to where there the
thing is
this is where we were I remember the
blared remember the blood Felix I'm in
better blood there's something changed
no you didn't how do I get back
no I'm not lost
okay maybe I'm lost whatever the grade
or the blue door helpful
that's one okay cool I don't know what I
would do without you guys honestly like
why would I just check a random [ __ ]
blue door maybe I'm an idiot no I
definitely am an idiot
hey let's go here hey exit Wow
wow that's so nice oh no oh oh jeez ah
thank you thank you
divide and conquer Oh God
oh this is bad boy
I [ __ ] up now oh it's locked it's like
that pardon in fear when you're the
[ __ ] corridor um just let me out
all right maybe there's a locker I need
to check out oh cool I can just chill
here Hillary Clinton sorry I just need
to break the ice a little bit Hillary
Clinton Jeb murder he fixes yeah blah
blah all [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you mean that's not cool man [ __ ]
you man
that ain't cool man [ __ ] a man
hey just Christ what an [ __ ]
maybe he just loves me
oh [ __ ] even the ceiling is trying to
spook me now are you ready
batteries [ __ ] yeah thank you Jesus
I appreciate you love you Jesus you're
the best
always there for me where now you're
need him should we just go to the exit
let's go to the ex with everyone tough
but I'm I ran into you wait still
doesn't well what do you want from me
huh my ass has never been clinched
harder than just now a relatable moment
in out less I check the computer what do
I do I'm a better lass here boys
No Hillary Clinton donate for Hillary
Clinton everyone all this this live
stream is all to support Hillary Clinton
you now movie the table took up the
ceiling I'm trying to move the table
which table can I move this one
Eric borne thank you I'm sad to not see
season two of scare PewDiePie
yeah I'm aside to I really am
which one do I move and it just it just
sucks out life is gonna be one of the
games to everyone worked so [ __ ] hard
that table for [ __ ] sake but hey what
can you do sometimes life's gives you
lemons and you just gotta lemonade him
here we go alright [ __ ] I hate these
[ __ ] vents just don't smoke
what the [ __ ] I was exciting for some
hentai like finally the game gets good
and yeah hey you're back in Arizona
welcome
Leon thanks to everyone for subscribing
everyone subscribe to become an hour
looks captain everyone
is there any way you can get the footage
well you could probably buy it
I don't know I'm hoping in the future
YouTube will soften up a bit I still
love you YouTube I still love you
you hurt me but I still need you we just
need time to heal there watching guys
there are deaths but [ __ ] man
Vera dad's not that far this isn't so
bad
all right yeah okay apparently he
doesn't [ __ ] one I walk as if you'd
[ __ ] die here if you survived all
these [ __ ] crazies ah what an earth
oh my god it's following the Bible ah ah
bad timing guys no
[Music]
[ __ ] Arizona Maine it's not a good
place to be I gotta say Arizona I'm
sorry I'm a little Arizona don't want to
know yeah just Lloyd holy [ __ ]
yeah just Lloyd I love you too men
appreciate you that was for you Oh what
the [ __ ]
what that [ __ ] happen now the [ __ ] is
coming oh [ __ ] it's a little man [ __ ] we
were just down with a [ __ ] we got a
little Danny DeVito actress now what the
[ __ ] man
we need to nuke area zone one shot one
kill [ __ ] really oh [ __ ] yes I'm
taking the long way I think that's been
the case for a while now dude [ __ ] it
start great now we got a [ __ ] mid jet
after us main not that that's a bad
thing I don't want to discriminate
against the slow people I just
you seem deadly and I don't like it just
don't kill me
Amanda Williams love your Felix here -
thank you matter Williams cheers oh [ __ ]
I hear the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this bad boys
batteries [ __ ] the [ __ ] is out there
he's out there somewhere we can walk
here take it easy now bros give some old
person a hug
I don't think stuff I dated a [ __ ]
once she was evil to the core all right
thanks for the info [ __ ] this place man
[ __ ] it oh [ __ ] it he's coming after me
[ __ ] how do I get over get over
ah [ __ ] more tech hey man I didn't know
you could donate like this on YouTube
it's super shet appreciate you man
[ __ ] where do I go
böck here we need to nooks corner [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm running out of battery - and
get keeps farting - its disgusting go
under the log and it looked like I could
oh now look I can't
the [ __ ]
thrown under the trees not crash oh my
god oh my god oh [ __ ]
what was that this is nice and cozy this
is definitely how I want to spend my
days but don't kill me [ __ ] mane
whatever you do do not kill me [ __ ]
means okay we're fine we're fine
everyone run run run this is run how the
[ __ ] did we end up in this hellhole man
all right let's be careful whoop whoop
zero deaths everyone zero deaths on this
live stream world's first zero debt ow I
broke my today yes that is correct you
heard me right stay low welcome to this
place of spiritual healing all right
thanks for the invite I think I'm gonna
pass oh god this is creepy be careful
thanks for the tip voice oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that
I don't know man I saw you die a little
bit before I died a little bit but not a
line that is a skinny [ __ ]
I could definitely oh no oh no [ __ ]
it's coming behind me
oh no [ __ ] this bad boys ah my ring I'm
wearing the headphones wrong again for
[ __ ] sake
no wonder I'm like confused about the
sound this is better than cam gross
Felix at least looks sexy plus I'll suck
your dick afterwards as well it looks
like a good time honestly I'd chill with
these [ __ ] I I've chilled with the
uglier how it hose that's right you know
I'll go in through their houses ever
have to jump up the morning to you how's
everyone doing you know it's a crack
it's a crack house
it's a : this is where the magic happens
batteries excellent damn you you [ __ ]
horn
you [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is your
big [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] threw up on
me [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I got
AIDS now what the [ __ ] man so the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah funny picked on ah are you
ugly ugly you're ugly get away from
peasants [ __ ] is that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it's one shot [ __ ] again
oh stop [ __ ] this is bad it's just real
bad bro it's real not good not good it's
bad that's bad brush I'm gonna have to
okay wha what my Jeff my Jeff's is
tangling [ __ ] me man sorry one second am
I the only one getting to stress the
[ __ ] out when I'm like is it as bad
watching I doubt it hey look guys I'm in
my studio I promise alright I'll I'll be
paying attention through the chat and
then I'll be uploading today's video
when I leave
Amanda Williams holy [ __ ] can I have one
more shot up it's been watching you
since beginning of course of course
Amanda I'll check out your channel you
seem like a great Amanda thank you so
much appreciate you what kind of music
should I put on I want to put on some
music I want it I'm officially done for
the day this is fun
I hope you guys enjoy the stream some
suicide balls how about that I had
student tense I want something mellow
some jazz I was having chili chili er
okay that's some good [ __ ] that's some
good background music hugs and kisses
from Japan thanks brew Lee Walker Harley
Kiner any advice and starting channel
and for equipment get a webcam and
condenser microphone and you're set
garlic and Parmesan senpai nerves me
please I just did
Laura McCready boots yeah it's bad to
watch it jesus [ __ ] christ I can't
I'm glad to hear that dragon there is a
cool stream and into your question
scares me [ __ ] to the cringe is real I
was reading a chat with all the
instructions thank you
this is too chilling it some Saint Pepsi
lovey bro mad respect Alexandra mana I
need to ask you a question well then ask
it let me know if it's too much place
sticky fingers and bootleg rascal what
the [ __ ] is that Ainsley Harriott thank
you for tipping juicy kisses sound time
Fridays are super chill Alice Alice and
rain yay love you thank you Chris and E
- Mexico loving out on like out camp
brofist Mexico I don't know what's a
sweaty sweaty beanie you missed my last
one I'm too poor for this sorry sweet
beanie I'll be paying attention to all
of them for now shaggy P well great name
watch your cry fair part 6 skip - ok I'm
curious what the [ __ ] happens there
[Music]
I'll check it out JD Salazar she thought
thank you Jake singer play
oh [ __ ] turtle chats I had to call my
bank because they thought someone stole
my debit card can I finally send another
message are you are you still doing the
shadow competition yes I am it's coming
up I'm working on it hope you like my
out live compilation I submit it for
Sherman I'll check it out this is just
the music I wanted so [ __ ] good
sea bass hello Pierce Vinnie well since
I watched you self-centered amnesia
that's [ __ ] awesome
dumb-bunny welcome welcome loreck's rape
please no to myself I love your videos
Masaki scarlet Thank You Marcia a lot
can you do some to me please
you want me to under sub subscribe
subscribe subscribe I'm kidding
scare PewDiePie you uploaded illegally
one of my episodes whatever okay puppy
sex love your vids enjoy your day can
you do a shout-out to me everyone shout
out to me leaves Beauty Sam lemon I want
to say hi also you like filthy Frank
filthy Frank is a [ __ ] awesome
Channel I think it's an inspiration to
me and a lot of channels out there just
for pushing boundaries and doing the
kind of [ __ ] no one else would think
about juicy kisses a lot I live in a
super strong a desert in Arizona that's
very religious the environment of out
life is too real for me Michael it's the
body
I'm a I am assuming the dead body send
news human triggers yes okay well this
is my penis
Simon recurse I hope this is good enough
for you
I'd say to catch up on uni work but here
I am instead a lot of hanging with your
periods much Australian go to sleep
its latest [ __ ] man can you sway in
Swedish jävla feet era of Korra I'm Anna
Williams again add me on insta peopie
and Amanda bear Hanuman a bear Hanuman
[Music]
welcome to D Goldie [ __ ] how you doing
buddy good how excited you free lie so
much - I'm so [ __ ] pumped for last of
us fear it's gonna be hella late buddy
nya lion much love from Hawaii been
following you since freshman year lovely
boots oh and always the Instagram plug
night
Nia yeah lion to her today
hey we got another hop currency some up
for you bro love you so much 2017 it's
the best bit
Oh your hair is still smashing
appreciate it can I have my forehead
back please no but you can have a mind
there you go inkling welcome to be
collection
goodbye batteries love you man
shailu love you bro can't wait for the
contest and watching everything since
amnesia I'm sorry the contest is taking
long we its guess how many [ __ ]
submitted 23,000 daemon mice again thank
you for being down there dude I love
your content you see when you do that
Damon thank you you seem like a cool kid
appreciate here I piss love you your
ghost for me to keep being you keep on
keep on brofist from California
thank you Anna Donna Adrian
what if the setting is actually in your
extended part of the three years of
jumping in power who knows
Ranger Jenny I'm working from home love
from Boston I'm glad you're watching
while not working sorry for keeping your
way Shia Mia
when will you play The Walking Dead as
soon as I can maybe tomorrow do you
still have a nice loose forehead can I
have it I still have it been a min Smith
what guitar do you play I actually sell
my guitar
are you cool time come on hey I make
chill music Alice my day job promise is
not crap ochio okay sounds good
I recognized a
have you ever heard much the apart
korzy new age' no mice in ever farts she
basically just just like that and I
assume she became a rocket for a few
seconds
welcome Ruben waarom welcome Maria moe
hey Bobby if I try to say my name hey
IVA kai is okay little ninja chick Robin
in California thanks me again if you
still have it why can I not have it I
look stupid without well because I'm
holding it hostage and you're in another
dimension
stormy can I tell my friend can you tell
my friend Jack dude Jack you're [ __ ]
MLG as [ __ ]
[Music]
Chevy I respect you man take it one
piece by the wall
brofist love your sense of humor you
guys are the ones that are taking it by
the box okay I'd be nothing without you
guys support honestly last stay for you
with that you have a plan a space party
the [ __ ] does that mean
or you just get smoking let's find our
outlets girlfriend [ __ ]
kids you're my inspiration watching you
for years would love to drink a beer
with you sometime bro from Indiana
Rustom Indiana brought this from
greetings from Louisiana been a
subscriber since day one
that's [ __ ] awesome Canadian can add
assassin it's one say everyone else have
your back and through all this YouTube
[ __ ] I really love your content
through salvation 22 Yvonne Bianchi
thank you concept giving in she hey kids
please subscribe me so much freely drago
swedish good about the remaining
suffering and yeah you want it so much
maybe you should check out doing i've
been having really having a really day
and make anyway but you're having a real
bad day I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm
gonna hang out with you guys much luck
from Stockholm best city in Sweden you
know what I'm from Gothenburg and I
gotta say I [ __ ] love Stockholm it's
a great city thanks for the dope stream
Thank You dingo Magnus always keep on
jingling can you follow me on Twitch
sorry I don't have I don't have not even
logged into twitch can you sub to me by
any chance love you papa fits well
[Music]
a little subsidy you ever gonna visit
amnesia again sometime if a really good
mod comes out bobby pewds
oh [ __ ] pig poo thanks for the shoutout
video you hit that mother
[Music]
sorry that was Bishop le le Thomas we
need more merch bro I'm working on son
it's almost done actually it's really
cool
for your information your life you loose
in Russian is a myth is that smell
y'all so yeah for a girl you're welcome
thank you
pick me Zi matter fades back she may
seem out of fate hey Pitts saw dude
we've been watching since day one you
wish I could make videos like you please
subscribe take a look at my super
annoying videos I'll have a look do you
have a lot of [ __ ] news day Bessie's
of the mac webcam i have ever seen
that's some good [ __ ] man I'll sub to
your channel man appreciate you can I
have in my forehead what the [ __ ] no
want to say thanks for the shoutout
video our wait I sorry I need scroll
down [ __ ] great tastes of music thanks
for making me smile everyday Thank You
Leon that's very nice gotta give you
another cut you hit that soundboard so
nice big thank you appreciate yes here's
to family friends families hit love for
money oh yeah
thank you boy hey stop
alright I'm gonna say another a couple
minutes and then I ain't gonna [ __ ] off
and then there'll be a video up money
key my name is Jeff pink tied at 50 sup
Felix made a nice little video based on
your lovely reaction next time why not
check it out
PewDiePie checks out my channel
pink Titan okay I subscribe to your
channel dude calm down
pink it tired of everyone paying tired
and appreciate you what camera to use it
looks [ __ ] amazing what can you say
in French a French bro je m'appelle
Felicia Java Dre Edgar - not to be here
I lost all my French this donation is to
make up for all the times I had adblock
on thank you leave else appreciate you
me about family-friendly Felix top
better bottom tier
tap bad about into you happily moaning
or was I also Journal ruined my youtube
channel and made me homeless do you have
any tips on how to survive spot unless
Greg you just you know if you can't beat
them join them take up a journalism
start studying in school infiltrate the
system 20 Mitchel hatch I don't mu right
now so much going on this is fun I'm
enjoying it I hope you're good dude
drinks drink beer sand finger your ass I
will I will do one of those things and I
won't tell you which one Dorothy
hype it's my friend Alison and I are
both big fans of you that's awesome
hope you help you help us cope with
anxiety and disorder every day and there
are no words to describe how much we
appreciate it keep doing what you love
also can you say hi to Alison for me hi
Alison and Dorothy thank you so much I'm
really glad my videos helped that really
means a lot appreciate ya pits
I'm inscribed since the early days of
amnesia absolutely content never played
to make me laugh man keep her your
awesome work brofist from Indiana
thanks man Tito take Saskatoon Hillary
Clinton titty hit that titty horn or tit
Oh can't get much since I got my Elsa
but wanted to that's so nice
I miss these times a game place I really
enjoy this this is really fun I have you
to read just for you now I'm a sponsored
love you rock man should be should be
working stop by to say thanks for always
making my day
brofist thank you that's awesome
appreciate all the support you guys are
too nice teal moon please don't stop
eighth note I know you love it oh okay
I'll play it I'm wrapping up guys so you
should stop me easy murderface hey piers
a minute oh wait [ __ ]
I need a [ __ ] see there we go did you do
it twice I made a video of me drinking
bleach and making fun of him at a time
I got deleted after 1 million views
please give me a moment of silence for
my life [ __ ] I don't know what to say
about that
that's a anyway you can do what you want
man you can do what you want and 6x
Oh dance to my remix of let me smash
[ __ ] into the strap mix man troffers
from Venezuela Venezuela
[Music]
alright I'm gonna upload a video now
guys it's gonna be up on my channel
comment Edgar has a tiny wiener everyone
here has a tiny wiener it's true
it is actually really small look at it I
got tiny this [ __ ] miniscule
it's [ __ ] Micro dick disappointment
to the whole family
alright let's publish this [ __ ]
show some loves show some support
publish in a new video it's pretty [ __ ]
to be honest it's a pretty [ __ ] video
I'm uploading to today just because how
[ __ ] god-awful
today's video is where's the philip
defranco lab also have you seen my
shitty shout out video
blink twice if you have
uh dragos Rosetta ku big lot from
Romania Romania your kundan is the best
it's obviously running out of ideas
thank you Norway is better than Sweden
[ __ ] you two Bs you don't know [ __ ] all
right guys I'm gonna wrap up thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
I had a lot of fun you guys are so
supportive and so nice and it really
means a lot it's really cool to say I
hope you had fun thank you thank you
lool Alice thank you snow Fox Thank You
Mohammed Thank You Ali Al Juma Happy
Birthday Avant oh and I hope you guys
have a great one
have a great great afternoon day morning
whatever the [ __ ] I'll see you tomorrow
check out the new video it's up on the
channel back